I gotta tell you okay the next Ant-Man
of course is coming out next year you
have received a lot of online advice
about how you could have defeated Thanos
all right
um and also are you taking notes from
this advice about Kang the Conqueror uh
I think I know what you're talking about
as there's a lot going on yeah yeah no
no but I I I know exactly I read it
exactly what you said through a lot of
chatter out there asking why I didn't
shrink down go in and uh
kill Thanos in a really creative way
first of all gross I know what you're
talking about about a way that uh to
kill Thanos
and that some people consider it a
missed opportunity
um well I guess you'll just have to see
the next one
so
it's gonna be
Batman
I don't know I don't know if you can
take Kang out that way either
Kang's pretty tough and I gotta assume
all parts of him are tough what are you
gonna do
I know what you
want you only murders in the building I
don't know I don't know anything about
it but you're in it I apparently from
what I've read
well you were in season two at the end
I was yeah yeah
I might show up here or there yeah yeah
but you can't tell us anything for them
especially it's a mystery show I I
really don't know anything I'm hoping
I'm waiting by the phone
so this is awesome this is really cool
this is such a fun event and uh these
kids are incredible it's so nice that
you know after having to sit it out for
a couple of years because of covet we're
back here and doing it in person I know
you've done this for almost 10 years
right it doesn't you know it doesn't
feel like it but I guess so yeah so why
is this organization something that you
feel very passionate about and want to
be a part of well you know it's an
amazing organization and it really
started as this Grassroots thing I was
in a play in 2006 and the character that
I played had a stutter and I really
didn't know that much about it and so I
kind of went online and was trying to
find somebody that I could talk to and
that's how I found Tara who who lived in
New York like me and um and so I met
with him and he said you should come to
one of our meetings and meet some of
these kids and I was so kind of knocked
out by them that I just stayed you know
involved as I spent some time with these
kids and I saw them kind of overcome
these obstacles and gain confidence and
see them come out of their ship out and
more and more kids joining the
organization and then writing plays and
Performing them it's just I was so
inspired that you know it's been 16
years that I've been involved now and uh
I'm continually Amazed by them it's the
kind of thing that people don't really
think about you know people like kids
that have anybody that has a speech
impediment or a stutter it's not
life-threatening so it doesn't really
get the attention but if you think about
it for just 10 seconds it's hard enough
growing up and they get bullied or
they're afraid to speak up in class and
they feel like they're you know alone in
the world to um
to kind of be able to help get some
confidence and overcome these things is
an amazing thing
our self-esteem through something like
this because we know
and I have I you know you see in the
kids and you'll see it tonight just how
incredible they are but if you talk to
any parent who uh has had a kid go to
camp at Camp say or been involved in the
organization
um they will inevitably start crying and
just talk about how this organization
saved their kids lives I mean it does
save lives I've seen a lot of I've been
reading the testimonial instead of been
showing up back there on the screens and
it is really really beautiful the first
time I ever did anything was a was a
Gala benefit and I hosted it and it was
at the skirball center and a little kid
came out to introduce me and he was
dressed up in a suit and ties about
eight years old and he's holding a
microphone and he could barely get any
of the words out and he's talking on
stage in front of hundreds of people I
found it to be the biggest the most
courageous thing I'd ever seen and I
instantly burst into tears and uh I
think that happens a lot tonight when
people kind of come to this thing they
don't know what to expect and um I think
they're touched yeah
foreign